should have filemaker be involved in the
marketing of their own films or leave it
to someone you say Charles is involved
in well yes at the level of dick night
there is no other choice you have to be
involved so it's tough for me to say
about this movie I mean in an ideal
sense probably not I would say I'm not
sure we're the best people to sell the
movie and you know it's it's a tough
thing of knowing because at each point
you kind of want the trailers you make
the purchase you make to often be the
thing that still represents you as an
artist rather than what represents the
movie best to a public and so it's a
tough line you know it's it's certainly
you know in the low of micro-budget
movie world you know that you know you
don't have that luxury so it's not
really an option and I guess I'm just
saying that it's almost a theoretical
thing even if I was making a big movie
of course you know you'd want he you
because if it was some something you'd
written and directed you wanna you know
your tie is so great to it you'd want to
feel like this vision is getting out
there but I think there is often a big
you know divide between what's in what
your movie is and in your mind and what
people get from the movie outside of you
you know the audience
you